avec noah manoir délégué syndical vigie
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france est ce que vous
comprenez que la loi sécurité globale
continue de mobiliser contre elle bien
entendu je pense que les manifestants
ont raison d'exiger le retrait total du
texte et non pas seulement l'article 24
parce que vous savez tout a été fait
pour concentrer l'attention sur cet
article 24 mai ce qui se cache en toile
de fond derrière ce texte de loi
c'est dans la logique ultra libérale
voulues par le gouvernement
la privatisation de la sécurité
d'ailleurs vous savez il ya eu un
discours très symptomatique de marley de
scapa qui est secrétaire d'état rattaché
au ministère de l'intérieur qui hier a
invectivé le maire de grenoble en disant
si le trafic de stupéfiants continue
dans votre ville c'est parce que vous
faites preuve de soumission et parce que
votre police municipale n'est pas armé
nous vous voyez on y est en fait je
pensais pas que ça viendrait aussi
rapidement
mais aujourd'hui l'état se retranche et
ce derrière un discours en fin de
déresponsabilisation de l'état alors que
la sécurité à la base est une mission
régalienne de l'état
mais aujourd'hui la représentante du
ministère de l'intérieur arrive à nous
dire que si le trafic de stupéfiants
prospère dans les zones urbaines
c'est la faute du maire qui n'investit
pas suffisamment dans sa police
municipale du monde y est
ce texte de loi vise à délayer l'escr
avis et les pouvoirs de police
judiciaire aux entreprises de sécurité
privées aux polices municipales
sam est à paris aujourd'hui ce ne sont
plus les agents de la mairie qui
verbalisent ce sont des sociétés privées
arènes lorsque vous êtes verbaliser vous
êtes transféré vers le service de
traitement automatisé des infractions
ce sont des opérateurs privés qui se
charge de gouverner lisez de vous
envoyer des courriers de traiter les
contestations etc etc
aujourd'hui on va vers une privatisation
justement de la sécurité dans son
ensemble à eurodisney les agents de
sécurité sont armés ils sont armés de
pistolets 9 mm comme l'est la police on
reste du territoire
donc on va doucement vers une
privatisation de la sécurité sur le
territoire national et cette loi
sécurité globale et va bien nous
âge de son article 24 qui vise à
exonérer les policiers de leurs
responsabilités parce que cet article 24
pénalise donc la diffusion malveillantes
d'image des forces de l'ordre et
pourtant on l'a vu la diffusion de
certaines images justement a permis de
révéler des comportements policiers pour
le moins et napperons inapproprié bien
entendu mais en fait c'est un message du
ministre de l'intérieur et l'ensemble du
gouvernement à l'endroit des forces de
police aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'intérieur se veut le défenseur
inconditionnel de la police nationale et
des agents de police y compris
malheureusement lorsqu'ils commettent
des forfaits vous savez pas plus tard
qu'il ya quelques minutes je lisais la
presse et on découvre qu'un policiers
des hauts-de-seine a été mise en cause
par la gendarmerie par ce qui leur
appartient à un réseau de pédophilie
internationale on a eu une policière à
paris qui a été confondu en flagrant
délit parce qu'elle a braqué un commerce
de proximité
on a tous ces affaires de violences
policières qui se superposent et la
logique du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est effectivement de faire le minimum
syndical pour réprimer ces actions mais
par contre pour ce qui est des
privations de liberté notamment
relatives à la diffusion de ces images
pour ce qui est de la persécution des
l'ancien d'alec à l'intérieur des murs
de la police nationale l'institution se
montre très active et c'est un signal
civile et qui nous amène doucement vers
quelque chose qui ressemble à une forme
de tyrannie
ou de totalitarisme si vous préférez
alors pointé du doigt aussi par les
manifestants un usage des caméras
piétons et des drones est ce que ces
outils sont aujourd'hui indispensables
pour le bon travail des forces de
l'ordre vous savez une caméra ne résout
aucun problème à celle à elle seule
c'est la façon dont ils utilisent dont
on peut l'utiliser qui fait que
finalement c'est son exploitation qui
est problématique qui peut ne pas l'être
bon les drones sous les ponts étaient
interdits sur la zone préfecture de
police par le conseil d'état donc
effectivement à la mairie par exemple de
saint germain en laye a ajouté sa police
municipale de drones possible et c'est
un outil un couteau peut servir à
blesser mais il doit aussi servir à
faire la cuisine
vous avez donc du coup la question
mérite d'être posée mais finalement
c'est que toutes ces questions se
rejoint aujourd'hui
moi j'ai aucun problème avec
l'utilisation des caméras piétons ou des
drones si je sais que derrière ces
caméras on a un policier content
consciencieux respectueux de la
déontologie
or aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu'un
policier commet un acte que j'ai qui
enfreint le code de déontologie il est
systématiquement au quasi
systématiquement exonérés de ses
responsabilités donc naturellement
aujourd'hui il faut mettre pause avant
de doter la police de nouveaux outils
notamment des outils de surveillance
il faut s'assurer justement que la
police soit garante des libertés
fondamentales et du respect de la
déontologie
ce qui est loin d'être le cas permettez
moi de profiter de votre antenne pour
j'ai suggéré et même très fortement que
les candidats à la présidentielle de
2000 22 se positionne sur ces questions
là est-ce qu'ils vont encourager la
police à aller dans ce sens là où est-ce
qu'ils vont envisager une réforme de
l'institution en profondeur donc à
l'heure actuelle nous avons jean luc
mélenchon également le professeur juvin
qui se sont déclarés candidats à la
présidentielle donc ils ne pourront pas
faire les cons
de s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils envisagent
en matière de sécurité pour nos
concitoyens mais également sur la façon
dont ils envisagent de gérer
l'institution police nationale et les
mystères de la merci d'avoir eu le temps
de réagir sur notre antenne des manoirs
délégué syndical vigie